- Le droit à l'avortement,
les États-Unis depuis
des décennies.nnies.
- And end abortion violence!
(cris)
- La décision de la Cour suprême
d'invalider Roe contre Wade
presque 50 ans après
son adoption ne fait
entre les deux camps.
Six des neuf juges affirment
qu'il n'existe aucune référens
la Constitution américaine
et qu'aucune disposition
ne sous-entend qu'il s'agit
d'un droit protégé
Il en revient doncaux États de.
13 d'entre eux s'étaient dotés
d'une loi gâchette. pour entrer
en vigueur une fois
Roe contre Wade renversé,
interdisent ou restreignent
encore un peu plusrtement.
Devant le plus haut tribunal
du pays, les réactions ont été
"Interdire l'avortementest illé
forcée est illégitime."
"Des millions de vies seront
sauvées grâce à cette décision.é
une victoire, affirme le leader
de la minorité de la Chambre
Le droit à la vie est protégé.
Les plus vulnérables ont
finalement une voix."
La décilammé
la sénatrice du Massachusetts.
"C'est une claque au visage
des femmes quant pre jugement
et d'exercer un contrôle
sur leur propre corps",
affirme Nancy Pelosi,
présiden
Le président des États-Unis
appelle les Américains à voter
massivemde mi-mandat.
"Cet automne, l'avortement,
à la vie privée et à la liberté
seront des enjeux électorauxéle,
affirme Joe Biden.
Pour régler la questionune foi,
le président estime
qu'il faudra élire une major vot
enchâsser le droità l'avortemeni
fédérale. Le camp pro-choix
n'a pas dit son de
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain, Radis